cette partie donc salut à tous bienvenue
dans ce troisième pré-draft hall on a
déjà parlé d épaisseur ce la dernière
fois on a déjà parlé du thunder la
première fois ce soir on s'intéresse aux
roquettes et le but c'est de répondre à
une question très simple qui peut drafté
houston qui devrait drafté houston sans
trop de prétention non plus et comment
ces joueurs peuvent s'insérer au projet
roquettes que ce soit dans le jeu que ce
soit aussi dans dans l'état d'esprit où
est ce que va cette franchise voilà on
va d'abord faire le diagnostic et
ensuite on va essayer de ne pas de
rapporter les différents prospects dans
l'effectif de houston à chaque fois pour
discuter de tout ça pour faire le
constat est ensuite discuté des
prospects on a un membre envergure ce
soir c'est l'immense benoît lelièvre qui
est barbu mais qui vieillit mieux que
james harden donc
favorable et toi ça va bien cette salle
play le projet roquettes sinon tu me
disais c'est le boxon
commença à wind on l'espère à 4 oui non
c'est
dans un état où la pression est plus un
beau bordel comme une maison en
rénovation présentement les requêtes
présentement il n'ya pas de plancher ya
pas de meubles et murs ont décapé c'est
suis assez triste on a eu un match 20
victoires cette saison mais toutes les
possibilités sont là use beaucoup de
flexibilité pour le futur
donc
c'est une équipe qui est en très bonne
position pour cette draft en fait
pour parler des roquettes nous avons
d'un côté le membre médias habituels de
chaque de chaque raid rafto c'est rémy
inversion in sport qui nous fait le
plaisir d'être ici savoir amis c'est
l'élève salut les gars bah ouais très
bien qu'ils comptent aurait pas eu tous
et de l'autre côté arthur du compte
rocket slime france qui va représenter
les fans puisque s'attendent à voir la
parole des femmes savard tue à vous
écouter il reste un peu des jeunes
garden ça va
merci je suis déçu parce que les les
deux les deux dernières fois il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait au moins 1000 soit
un maillot du thunder sont un maillot
d'épaisseur moi j'ai essayé de faire
semblant de mettre un truc qui ressemble
au rocket c'est en fait c'est maillot de
são paulo
mais bon
départ et de carton jaune pour la tenue
vestimentaire ben tu parlais bonjour à
tous dans le chatt merci beaucoup d'être
là posez vos questions à laizy on y
répondra en temps voulu ben tu parlais
de maisons en construction rémy
je te pose la question tout de suite moi
le projet roquettes ça ressemble à quoi
le projet raphaël stone avec les
roquettes et ensuite on ira sur les
détails du roster mais n'a de ton point
de vue
vaste question
alors déjà comme l'a dit ben le truc
situe la saison qui vient de se terminer
la pire équipe de nba mathématiquement
ça qu'on s'a
donc partant de là c'est compliqué tu
étais dans l'année un de tarot
construction 300 postes de james harden
qui a été le voilà le
déclencheur de toi nous sommes le départ
de james harden
année un tas fait le pari d'en
construire par la grave tu avais pas
trop le choix de façon on a eu quatre
clics de dark l'année dernière tu as
beau john ging qui est censé être le fer
de lance du truc juste à des bonnes
surprises de la dette juge christopher
est une bonne surprise il semblerait
qu'elle prenne chelghoum ça me prenne
bien donc tu as des trucs intéressants
qui se met en place et donc là tu
arrives dans le land de tarot
construction tu as encore des pics
élevés depuis tout alpiq 3 de la draft
qui est hyper intéressante alpiq 17
aussi qui est qui peut servir dans un
package éventuel donc tata plein
d'options sur cet art tu peux
tu peux décider de très noble de traits
d'armes de piqué à tat choix
moi je pense que la question en appelant
à plein de questions annexes on rentrera
dans le détail tu as raison du roster
tout à l'heure mais je pense que ta
question principale est aujourd'hui
quand il houston je pense que la réponse
est nécessairement oui je pense que
c'est difficile de dire non déjà c'est
de savoir si oui ou non john green et
ton franchise player dernière voilà pour
moi c'est ça le truc si tu crois
toujours et je pense que tu dois croire
que oui si tu crois que c'est le cas tu
construit autour si tu commences déjà
dotée d'un stade qui serait quelle
mauvaise il est au bout d'un an il faut
que tu cherches un autre talent
générationnel
atur comment tu réponds à cette question
comment toi tu le vois et surtout plus
ont ressenti d'abord mais aussi je suis
vachement la roquette comment le gm il
s'est exprimé à propos de sa
com quel est l'endroit de jeff green est
ce que c'est vraiment la locomotive pour
la suite et du coup
ça veut dire à cette draft on recherche
plus peut-être un complément un ring man
que cette locomotive
ouais bah écoute il ya plusieurs
plusieurs développements en cours c'est
vrai que l'impression qu'on avait eu
pour un pur ok c'était il y avait un
développement autour de kevin parent
tanger nord sur le point guard ça c'est
un premier gros développements ce que je
t'avoue c'était le seul vrai meneur
parce que john roll était estimée sur le
plancher
et du coup pas de jeanine green pour
l'instant oui est vue comme la star
montante des roquettes nous on y croit
on y croit dur comme fer quand surtout
quand on voit ça sa deuxième partie de
saison
après deux des infos que j'ai pu un peu
voir dans les différents médias des
roquettes s'est pour la prochaine draft
drafté du coup pas au film est vraiment
au talent il y met de ramener si tu veux
un joueur qui a un peu une aura montré
un potentiel doha de stars pour par la
suite être plutôt attractif voilà son
marché de la fréquence et ça c'est la
première info et l'autre un fossé que
l'année prochaine le temps qui est
désarmé en partie je pense parce que
cela fasse mais en tout cas le prix prix
on veut veut gagner des matches en tout
cas c'est le projet
donc à voir est ce qu'on va chercher la
victoire l'année prochaine apparemment
c'est pas l'option numéro une dans toute
la maison
est ce que je me permet à alex est ce
que toi qui suivent quelques trucs que
nous est ce que le temps qu'il va pas
être désarmé comme c'est souvent le cas
jusqu'en jusqu'en janvier puis
finalement
à soi rolex
je suis un peu plus l'habitude de
houston que nous je pensais étiez
souvent les équipes elle dit ça les
équipes qui qui partent avec de grosses
ambitions personne peut dire on part
avec le temps car mais tu vois personne
ne va dire on va tenter on en octobre
heureusement d'ailleurs dit merci
décembre janvier février ça dépend un
peu des saisons au bois tu réalises que
est ce que est ce que tu crois pas
qu'ils sont un peu le cas de nouveau dû
cette année que l'année prochaine c'est
possible en tout cas les plans de ce que
je peux voir un peu tu vois par exemple
eric gordon et hewitt qui sont
considérés comme des vétérans chez nous
reste dans les plans d'eric est en tout
cas on n'a pas l'impression qu'ils vont
être testés ou en tout cas en partie
mais c'est pas non plus l'option dauphin
c'est pas la strate l'une d'eux d'être
agressif et des lâchers cet été moi je
pense qu'ils seront encore dans lost
heures à la rentrée donc oui on y croit
à moitié la déclaration je t'avoue mais
après ça fait plaisir de voir un peu que
bah ouais on essaie peut-être de chez un
plugin potentiellement après toute la
saison mais a mais oui on y croit on est
qu en matière
ben on va on va commencer à se projeter
tout doucement mais d'abord sur cette
question de l'escaut john green elle est
la première option parce que dans cette
draft pour toi
encore une fois d'une modestie et il ya
des joueurs qui ont des plus de stars
potentielles que jane grey
dans la position des
derricks est cependant jugé vraiment
jusqu'à la question est ce qu'on achète
le mr sunshine ou non et encore le sait
pas prouvé que vu qu'on n'a pas vu
beaucoup cherchent à jouer on l'a vu
jouer majoritairement sont en balance
pour prouver qu'ils ne peuvent pas jouer
ensemble mais ça dans leur position on
parle de d'aller chercher deux
troisièmes des doux du joueur à au
tableau ça veut dire à ventre chez tong
wen jiabao ismet et palau bancaire ou
celui que les deux équipes en deux mots
qui s'y est orlando ne veulent pas
mais sinon c'est ça moi je pense que
c'est frais de ces trois joueurs là ce
serait d incroyables complément à john
ging mais ce soit si on veut viser
si on veut viser les nuages si on veut
viser vraiment très haut pour revendre
la seule option c'est chez d'un tshirt
mais je ferai moi ça serait pas ce que
je ferais si j'étais houston cette année
je serrais de continuer de construire la
colonne vertébrale de cette équipe lors
en ajoutant un du talent je miserais pas
sur les toits des choses présentement
pour développer un joueur qui à propos
de qui on ne sait pas grand chose
très bien on va on va juste jeter un
oeil au roster et rémy je vais je vais
te poser la question parce qu'il ya
quelques points d'interrogation est pour
toi qui sont les qui sont les joueurs de
l'as de la colonne vertébrale qui sont
les joueurs à conserver pour les
requêtes et qui sont bas des as est
simplement mal sans leur faire injure ou
quoi mais mais voilà j'ai j'ai séparé le
roster en trois grands thèmes alors
j'essaye de faire moderne et de pas
mettre pgs gsf et fc mais plutôt par
mine avec tes rôle de porteur de balle
de plus se délier qui va écarter le jeu
et de other d'écran ou
gens qui vont couper au panier et donc
ça donne ça
kevin porter juniors jeunes role players
auction des knicks
[Musique]
tricia mots que j'ai mis de winx on
verra c'est discutable et et côté big on
a cinq bungaroo bas kenyon martin junior
et oui pour les lignes sont à la timone
juste arthur
gesundheit ils vont activer la team
option j'imagine donc pas cher
on va les voir l'acte iv on parle à peu
près à deux entre 12 et 15 millions je
crois la saison en fait il qu'on est
content il compte l'euro sinon ils vont
le prolonger
rapidement
et après il ya des contrats non garantis
c'est à dire garrison matthews notamment
et j'ai mis des points d'interrogation à
que je vole et eric gordon rémy pour toi
c'est quoi ça sert ils vont êtres vont
tenter d'être très des ce qu'on va les
garder mon tour
le problème c'est que alors tu as
beaucoup de flexibilité dans le dr
auster cette année tu peux faire
beaucoup de choses quand elton et déjà
c'est quand même une luxe pour un point
g m thual inverse de chez pas des lakers
qui tu veux ou les mecs sont galère pas
faire grand chose quant à james key main
luxe de pouvoir faire des choses lara
preston le gel des roquettes il peut
faire plein de trucs
ou des gordon ces deux très bonnes
questions surtout christian ude
christian ude il reste une année de
contrat et qui est pas cher pour ce qui
produit une année à 14 ou 15 millions je
vais regarder
pour un mec de ce niveau de talent et de
production c'est pas cher payé donc
c'est sa dernière année de contrat bon
moi je pars du principe que l'année
prochaine de houston elle va encore une
fois pas ça va pas ça m'a grand chose
pas vrai je suis mauvaise entame en tout
cas où tu vas pas viser grand chose je
suis même pas persuadé je vous
souhaiterais vraiment du fond du coeur
de viser le le plein je trouve pas ça
très réaliste mais donc partant de là je
me dis qu est ce que tu as vraiment
intérêt à conserver chritian août
c'était pendant un an et le perdre
contre rien l'année prochaine alors que
oui il va t'aider bien sûr qu'il m'a
aidé à gagner plus de matchs l'année
prochaine mais pour quoi faire alors que
si tu t'en sers cet été qui chez nous
moi je pense que avec un contrat une
année de contrat à 14 millions il va
intéresser un paquet des kippas côté qui
voudrait elle gagner maintenant et ça
pourrait permettre de récupérer des
assets supplémentaire donc déjà un choix
à faire là dessus tu vois est ce que tu
conserves good pour être un petit peu
compétitifs et tenter d' espérer
peut-être au début voir comment ça se
passe pour aller chercher un prix où est
ce que dès cet été tu t'en libère pour
peut-être le package avec autre chose
encore une fois flexibilité de cette
équipe tapis trois pics 17 caisses qui
t'empêche si jamais tu fantasmes je dis
n'importe quoi tu re sur cetto m'bengue
rennes par exemple j'en sais rien je
suis pas dans la franchise mais
imaginons que le gm il fantasme sur
pyatov des caisses qui l'empêchent de
package et le pic trois plus riches
genou droit en l'occurrence pour orlando
ça peut-être pas m'intéresser mais tu
vois ce que je veux dire tu as des
possibilités de pâques et déjà faire
dans un sens comme dans l'autre en tout
cas donc ça ça c'est à voir eric burdon
moi ça me paraît moins évident parce que
sa valeur marchande aujourd'hui est
moins intéressante que celle de chris
shaw wood mai mais je ne serais pas
surpris qu eric gordon il reste là pour
cette dernière saison après tout le
reste façon c'est des jeunes joueurs qui
sont hyper intéressant qu'il faut garder
ta une décision à prendre kevin porter
en jeûnant société
est-ce que tu le hais ce que tu me
prolonge ou pas tu peux le tu peux lui
offrir une extension dès cet été ou
attendre l'année prochaine ce qui peut
être un risque aussi moi j'aime bien le
petit show knicks ont signé en fin de
saison là qui sortait de gilly qui a
fait deux trois trucs sympas je pense
que c'est un mec installation à
surveiller
moi si tu me demande mon avis toute
façon c'est cette équipe de houston je
pense qu'elle doit pas avoir d'immenses
ambitions pour l'année prochaine et il
faut qu'on commence développer des
jeunes tu as une question a répondu au
tour de chris young ou d' une question
autour de porter junior et tu
complémentera ça avec des avec des
joueurs autour comme tu le peuple il
faut continuer à développer les jeunes
toute façon c'est le projet le
l'ambition pour eux c'est 2023 24 c'est
pas 2022 23
on a plusieurs plusieurs commentaires
dans le schatz annuaire qui est d'accord
avec toi qui dit good dehors faut monter
à la draft ou obtenir des pics pour les
années un plus tard ben je te faire
bondir là dessus avant d'aller vers
arthur pour savoir s'il ya des petits
bruits de couloir déjà à ce niveau là de
deux routes qui sont richard d1 déjà
c'est pas un propos de woods mais les
hornets magasin de réelles 13e pic et
moutons qu'ils entrent
maintenant qu'ils entrent en mode on
veut gagner maintenant reculer au numéro
17 avec christiane bois delà on parle de
quelque chose qui serait intéressant et
pratique aussi pour un label au bol un
prospecteur à la question du web qui
capable de défendre
[Musique]
car elle à l'heure je crois pour les
deux équipes
peut-être ajouter un peu de côté
ouais
de 17 à 13 c pas beaucoup
tout dépend du joueur que tu suives bien
sur les toits dès que tu laisses ton
aussi de fifi une équipe qui veulent
prendre 14 dans le paquet pour monter à
13 moi je voulais donner la parole sur
parmi les trois dont on en parlait
jabbari paulo chaîne peut-être fait un
peu moins à l'aise javari paulo est-ce
que cristiano de cire est il peut pas
prendre des minutes à ségala et ans est
gêné un petit peu leur développement
surtout surtout à jack harris mais
surtout à jabbari smet par la bac héros
c'est une toute une autre proposition je
crois qu'on peut jouer par le bnq héros
avec que sur le web sur le terrain mais
que j'abhorre ici mais rejette comme
étant
une espèce de shu par accrétion web
capable de défendre que la position
capable de shooter à trois points foot
déjà de mieux que wayne je crois à mon
avis la mécanique de ces magnifiques le
registre le nombre le nombre de
situations dans lesquelles il s'est donc
oui sauf si on y va pour un job à vis
mais
arthur quel est le
lait les bruits qu'on a deux des
roquettes sur ceux sur cristiano de ce
qu'on est et ce qu'il y en a ou excuse
finalement il n'y a rien qui sort on est
con ses parents à droite pas savoir
quoi dans le cloud c'est assez calme
résilié culte et de rumeurs c'est
pendant la trêve de février dernier mais
je crois ce que j'ai lu il n'y a pas
beaucoup ce n'était pas non plus proche
d'un deal c'était vraiment tester le
marché mais je pense que cet été a quand
même des
débris qui vont encore courir
autour de moudon comme tu l'as dit rémi
savait que ce serait un peu dommage de
potentiellement de prendre la place d'un
manque héros d'un gabarit 24 ans de
prendre des minutes sur la saison
prochaine et en plus de ça ne pas
utiliser la valeur de woods et qui le
restera du coup on en comptera donc je
pense que la meilleure solution c'est de
traits de cet été mais sincèrement j'ai
l'impression que ce n'est pas du tout le
plan des roquettes qui sont pas vraiment
qu'ils n'ont pas le sentiment d'urgence
de lâcher dès cet été c'est eux que
woods apparemment il a des très bonnes
relations avec le coach avec le
président et c'est d'autant plus
difficile d'être activé ça donc c'est
que c'est un peu l'impasse est un peu le
gros débat au sein de la fanbase des
roquettes c'est ce qu'on resigne c'est
oui pour combien parce que parce que moi
je fais partie de ceux qui sont hyper
partagé dans le sens lâcher parce qu'il
ya du talent l'intérieur qui va arriver
mais de l'autre c'est vrai que c'est un
ca son contraste un peu du pain béni le
ratio et il est plutôt bon donc oui le
resigner potentiellement et le décalé
sur un poste 4 parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu le center
petite pierre d'eyraud casse donc je
suis à trop d'interrogations dans le
cinq majeur tabac trois joueurs qui sont
titulaires qui sont pas vraiment leur
pose c'est un peu le bazar je pense que
là après la draft de cette année on y
verra plus clair à court terme
christiane route donc le gros point
d'interrogation un des points
d'interrogation de cette intersaison
côté roquettes on va se poser les
questions maintenant messieurs
qui fait le plus rock'n des roquettes
c'est une équipe qui court mais qui
courent mal hein dernière
efficacité la pire de la ligue sur les
situations de transition mais top top 10
en ce qui concerne la fréquence et tom
équipe qui concerne le plus de
transition aussi de champ sans
transition à ses adversaires
ça c'est pour une identité de jeu on va
dire juste statistiques rémy toile et
les roquettes
tu les vois les voit jouer comment et
par rapport à cette question quel genre
de grand tu mettrais avec john green
pour
danton saintais latham young rennes
paulo tchèque lamy de froid en grèce et
il ya déjà barry smith
j'imagine à la ligne est
effectivement s'accordent
écoute toi sont onze ans qu'il et
pendant ce temps là je réponds à ta
question e on peut on peut fantasmer
autant qu'on veut et
bien 300 dans le basket toujours de
petits et les petits what if lequel
serait le mieux chez les roquettes moi
tu sais que tu as je te dis que tu es un
mec hyper pragmatique et terre-à-terre
et la réalité de ce que je comprends
bien là pour commencer à m'intéresser
vraiment assez dark qu'on fera sur bing
com d'avant là c'est que j'ai eu quand
même dit fortement l'impression que chet
et jabbari smith se détache le haut
place 1 et 2 dans un ordre à affiner et
donc tu as ton houston pic à 3,6 tenté
qui concerne leurs pick 3 équilibré pas
un pou d'armes et ben ils prendront ce
qui restera et il semble de plus en plus
que ce soit paulo banque héros qui soit
le troisième pour l'instant puisque je
rentre en tout cas vous avez peut-être
d'autres infos mais moi de ce que
j'entends il semblerait que c'est ça
donc on peut se poser plus de cette
question là est-ce que paolo bancaires
aussi bien aux oraux quatre mois j'ai
l'impression que oui j'ai l'impression
que oui parce que c'est un mec qui a un
qi basket qui me semble hyper avancé
pour son âge et je pense vraiment que
même s'il décide de garder krichen woods
ce que je pourrais comprendre parce que
ce dont on parle est à leur bon bah oui
ok ça paraît plus évident pour l'avenir
de traits décrit chez nous de la même
temps que tu fais un choix qui est
catastrophique en terme d'image auprès
des fans belges parce que tu fais ça ça
veut dire que tu fais une croix sur ta
saison qui vient donc s'ils font le
choix de ce qu'il serait respectable de
pas très décrit chez nous pour jouer le
jeu de la saison prochaine
imaginez une association ou de banques
héros avec en plus
le côté alors je ne sais pas si vous
dassa en lui mais peut-être le côté un
peu mentor aider au développement quoi
j'ai l'impression banques et rolling
stones ça pourrait fonctionner et puis
surtout je vous répète c'est un mec qui
est formé à lyon donc a priori et
qu'elle posait qu'elle réfléchit
toujours été le cas mais lui c'est son
car j'ai l'impression
dans une équipe de houston qui est m
comme dit mon quart chez nous qu'ils
allaient fils qui se touchent
régulièrement je pense que ça
apporterait un peu de sérénité donc j'ai
l'impression banques et rossé serait pas
mal pour une somme
arthur avant de donner la parole à peine
sur balles le la descriptif pour ceux
qui connaissent pas trop encore de ses
prospects différents
et c'est eux tu peux me parler de cette
identité de jeu j'ai dit une équipe qui
court et qui courent mal en résumant
grossièrement mais déjà dit en citant
jacques monclar les fils qui se touchent
est ce que c'est un peu ça c'est une
équipe qui a besoin de peut-être d'un
peu plus de calme dans son identité de
jeu au contraire c'est une équipe qui a
besoin d'un gars qui bien avec une
mentalité de
d'être complètement fou
non mais là tu l'a très bien dit jérémy
et puis jacques monclar aussi au passage
mais c'est vrai que en plus de ça je le
disais tout à l'heure qui appuie jean
c'est qu'on en parle peu mais déclare
dans la reconstruction des roquettes ils
pensent qu'à l'intérieur qui peut amener
cette sérénité et peut-être va calmer le
jeu de temps à autre
c'est plutôt pas mal pour accompagner
pizza qui doit apprendre beaucoup encore
son pick and roll et c'est pas mal de
domaines donc et puis moi le fond de
court tsonga won paul gayraud défense
seulement à voir mais en tout cas en
attaque ça fait à première vue
ok bon des fois défensivement c'est
compliqué
ben
gaudin est ce que
parce que rémy
paraissait
pragmatiquement nous éliminer en graine
est semée
c'est les bruits qui sont là à un mois
quasiment jour pour jour de la draft
est ce que toi tu y crois est ce que
pour toi ya un grand écart
que les que que aung rennais smith vont
être un et deux
la seule et quand que moi j'ai entendu
repoussé chez tong wen chong wei est au
dessus de tout le monde à la draft j'ai
entendu aussi que ok s'ils préféraient
jabbari ce maître pour l'instant mais où
qu'ici c'est un peu comme une machine à
bingol il va sortir une boule chaque
fois et on voit on se sait jamais qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire le soir la draft
mais oui par le bnq héros à
ayew n
moi j'aime j'aime l'idée j'aime son
papier je sais pas quel point ça va
fonctionner
mais son papier le touché de passeurs de
ban queiroz surtout
parce que son on a tendance à penser à
huy les deux procureurs à la mène ils
vont bouffer tout il ya il
leur faut des gars à alimenter leur faut
alimenter près du poste comme ça peut
être contraire aussi le compte du bon
score de m ça peut être un joueur
d'intérieur qui les alimentent aussi
pour avoir justement un joueur avec une
vision comme par la banque héros à
houston que ça complètement très je
pense bien le côté hyper athlétique
hyperactif que l'écueil houston montre
sur le terrain -
moi j'ai mes idées je suis en paix sur
papier humide et ça on pas tant d'être
un désastre dans la vraie vie mais sur
papier je trouve que ça fait de chance
et les séries c'est que j'aime bien
regarder aussi l'état d'esprit la
psychologie que ça marche aussi avec des
joueurs un peu fou fou je pense que pas
de match parfait dans les trois joueurs
au tableau je crois que justement
jabbari smit
achèterez avec eux trop cette mentalité
là qui est déjà un peu fou fou au départ
et que ça à éteindre est peut-être
quelqu'un comme comme chez tong wen qui
a toujours été dans les environnements
hyper structuré au minnesota où à
gonzaga donc plus espèce de far west la
haye houston je crois que ça allait
tendre est peut-être donc on parle aux
banques et rockit habitué aux situations
d'oppression qui est habitué
bhatti qui tue c'est un peu un far-west
russie à diou console en 60 ans s'était
pas c'est un peu le cas aux souvent sur
le terrain donc je pense qu'il y aurait
peut-être côté tempérament le meilleur
des trois tempéraments pour gérer cette
situation qui prend nécessairement mot
valise mais quitte en quittant en flux
le quitte en état de renouvellement
ça va peut-être passer par un changement
de coach aussi si ya pas de ces
cinquante roulettes la kawa
rémy je sais que tu dois bientôt y aller
pour pour conclure là dessus pour
conclure avec toi est ce que est ce que
tu penses que si effectivement comme tu
le dis chet et jabbari son parti
est-ce que houston va se tourner
effectivement vers un paulo même s'ils
se disent le talent est un peu
équivalent ou est ce qu'ils vont se dire
où on peut aller drafté au talent ce
qu'avait l'art de dire arthur au début
on peut aller chercher à ivy si on
trouve qu'il est meilleur on peut aller
chercher un chat bien qu' ils soient des
joueurs potentiellement ayant plus
besoin du ballon que qu'un parole au pad
je suis d'accord à 100% avec arthur là
dessus
houston non seulement peu mes doigts
drafté au talent c'est une équipe qui
est trop tôt dans sa reconstruction pour
se permettre d'aller chercher des
déficits et se dire allez nous manquer
il nous manque je sais pas et de la
défense au périmètre où il nous manque
j'en sais rien c'est trop tôt dans la
reconstruction l'équipe et naulleau qui
tout en vala de tout ça
là le but c'est d'accumuler du talent il
faut prendre du talent donc ils doivent
faire ça maintenant encore une fois on
n'est pas dans les work hard pré draft
on ne peut pas assister à ça
malheureusement mon coeur je peux pas
vous dire si bancaire on sera bien le
troisième le plus gros talent de sedrata
semblerait de loin oui mais c'est pas
sûr donc je pense que houston a même
l'obligation d'aller chercher d'aller
chercher du talent ils peuvent se
permettre ce luxe là de se dire bon
limitons tant que c'est pas des paris
parce que à paris sur un pick 3 c ce
serait beaucoup trop risqué mais tu vois
ce que je veux dire ils ont besoin de
prendre ils ont besoin de migrer dès le
niveau de talent de son roster c'est
évident de toute façon la rencontre sera
longue et houston va pas jouer le titre
dans les trois ans qui viennent c'est
sûr donc ils peuvent prendre sur lui que
cela d'avoir du temps prenez les plus
forts joueurs et vous verrez après
comment vous les fait de jouer ensemble
mais prenez les plus forts voire très
bien le mot de la fin
tu dois y aller c'est ça ouais je vais
devoir je dois vous laisser tas d'autres
choses et moi non je voulais je voulais
que tu nous disais il ya une interview
de housses matière sur le
web on a lu
ousmane tout à l'heure dans nba extra
c'était très cool
qui est un gamin très posé très calme
est intéressant et et dont la cote avait
pas de monter c'est ouf là il ya la
plupart des morts que l'annoncent
loterie picaros man donc on verra où il
sort je les ai vus même annoncée du
début d'une oeuvre j'ai vu lieu de 12 à
vos questions je lui aurais eu plein de
trucs pour lui
donc à voir mais mais ousmane gamin très
sympa et et mon petit conseil comme ça
je vais faire mon auto promo mais
regardez le dit extra demain parce qu'on
a une annonce vers 13 heures pile on va
vous faire une annonce eu un peu
particulière bon eh bah c'est noté pour
pour les assidus de nba extra et même
pour ceux qui qui ne serait pas
forcément habitués à l'émission mais qui
nous écoutent vas-y je termine puisque
comme c'est la routine et s'il veut
toujours de nous la draft sera bien sûr
toujours en live sur bin sport cette
année le 23 juin au soir et normalement
son altesse romain leroy de la team
envergure bras dans le casting à nouveau
c'est bien noté
normalisation est lancé
normalement là on a rendez-vous
effectivement
pour être présent à travers la présence
de l'élégant romain leroy sur le plateau
de the bean le soir de la draft merci
rémi d'être d'être devenu parler des
roquettes merci les gars bercow chao bon
courage pour le maroc consignes allaient
tous là je sais que ça marche merci
merci les goûts de l'accord aux 400
courage à toi tu vois
merci
messieurs où là on est en trop libre où
on continue sur poweo ou arthur est ce
que toi tu as entendu d'autres choses
d'autres rumeurs
écoutez pas beaucoup d'infos on sait
même pas cléroux qui ont été interviewés
par les bras des roquettes la seule info
voilà quand je dis c'est vraiment garder
sept ans quatre chercher le maximum de
sécurité pour l'année prochaine ou
l'année suivante voilà pour ce n'est des
free-agents sait tous qu'on a un peu
parlé de gens volent tout à l'heure mais
john lobb du couvent à qui va quitter
l'équipe cet été quasiment sur soi un
bail out
plus gordon qui pourrait partir plus
vous donc ce afin de la masse donc faut
vraiment voilà comment on l'a dit
prendre le meilleur talent possible et
un peu voilà celui qui pourra peut-être
avoir stora de stars que green semble
avoir aussi pour vraiment rester une
destination attractive sachant qu'en
plus on est à l'état il ya le moins de
taxes je crois de mémoire loin d un des
plus faibles taux donc on reste un
marché
ben la question de la paix dans le tchat
qu'est ce que t'en dit
c'est moi j'ai beaucoup confiance en le
potentiel de chez nous chez soi que ça
va
ça va tomber
sur des panneaux ce qui va tomber john
green j'y crois aussi beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup il manque peut-être un
peu de coffre mais sa mort n'est avec
l'âge
moi je me risque réel ni surcharge ni
sur
et avec le talent et la sécurité c'est à
dire on a deux porteurs de ballon hyper
hyper actif
donnons leur des athlètes dont la des
joueurs à qui passer le ballon puis un
joie comme parlant qu'un autre chose que
j'aime ce qui ralentira un peu le jeu et
puis donner un peu une dimension
affronte alla le france yves des
meilleurs
donc donc toi dans ton dans ton board
personnel
à heavy comme sharqc ils sont un cran en
dessous de banques héros et de semis des
jets à l'instinct oui je mettrais
peut-être cinq héros chuck et jabari a à
un point b puis dans le 2e tiers 2
commenceraient avec
avec dieu dans la vie ok ok je vois
qu'il ya pas mal de fans de jason
évident le chat crise pourquoi tu mets
un petit peu en dessous
du la cinquième effectivement sur ce
genre de et
pourtant tu aimes bien le profil du
joueur je vais mettre en en partage
d'écran ton scoot in report mais dis moi
pourquoi tu es un peu en dessous
sur le
seul sol très
général je pas convaincu à quel point il
va être capable
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai négocié âprement
ses ports ses socios qui joue beaucoup
en pick and roll qui joue beaucoup à 1 à
2 à 3 n'y a pas un gars qui frôle
général qui râlent et
les autres joies de son équipe mais pas
pour l'instant pas la lamelle obole par
exemple qui comprend ou donner le ballon
acquis qu'un jet dans la vie faut jouer
à son propre rythme et puis c'est
correct
comme ça
serait un peu compliqué
arthur sur deux terrains belle parler du
feedback héros sur demi terrain ça donne
quoi la tacc des roquettes c'est ce
qu'on est plus sûr beaucoup de pick and
roll est ce qu'on va aller jouer sur
d'isolation com comment comment
fonctionne cette attaque avec avec coach
chiche silas à
s'agacer on est une des pires équipes
sur deux mutins de la ligue on va voir
la 30e
mais c'est un jeu finalement qui
pourrait vraiment convenir à banque
héros c'est à dire que on a vu pas mal
de situations tu as du goût des 2,5
gones qui restent pointés à 3 points
donc au final il ya pas mal de l'espace
à l'intérieur ce qui a beaucoup profité
à john higgins la fin de saison tu as
beaucoup de passes ma main est une sorte
de fausse swing avec vraiment toi le
pivot qui est qui est vraiment à
l'extérieur
et dans l'axé du panier donc c'est un
peu la constitution de bases on va dire
des roquettes finalement très peu de
systèmes worth et des systèmes qui sont
très rapides et qui finissent culture du
pick and roll qui épie 10 et une good
slash woods donc au final le système
offensif est pas vraiment bien rodée
pour le moment en défense j'ai pas envie
de forêt d'othe a mené l'assaut donc
donc donc voilà et on a pu remarquer
aussi que au final on on a quand même
beaucoup de tirs ouverts à trois points
tu vois par exemple qu'on est et on a
fait cette victoire de suite je crois
après avoir fait quinze défaites dessus
trois heures on est la première équipe
de l'histoire à rézé ce genre de perfs
on a vu nos shooteurs shooter de manière
admirable et au final c'est un système
où en fait c'est apad adresse et que son
pick and roll tu plantes pas c'était
très compliqué donc c'est un peu du
quitte ou double on va dire pour
l'instant roquettes avec toujours ce
meneur qui doit apprendre
et qui a et qui a appris sur la fin de
saison il a il a vachement fait baisser
ses ballons perdus etc si je me trompe
pas
vraiment ça il a pris il était bien plus
à l'aise et puis même dans son perso ça
va un petit peu mieux si sur la fin de
saison on a pu vraiment se vend on a pu
le voir s'épanouir vraiment
admirable enfin saison c'était très cool
de le suivre et là apparemment il fait
un gros travail sur son physique cet été
donc à voir comment il va il va revenir
simplement plus en forme et peut-être
avec plus de fondamentaux ce qui va
aussi de retravailler avec avec erding
ce
set était donc pas 60 collectif en tout
cas son bundle ou des choses un peu plus
perso
ben si on rentre dans le détail de la
mécanique offensive paolo guerrero il
amène quel genre de possibilités
efficace sur demi terrain
bah ils amènent partenaires de pick and
roll salle y admirer leurs partenaires
de pékin pop il plus il peut manier le
ballon un peu il peut passer surtout
donc on parle ici de maximiser
le talent du scoring de l'ariège qui
score vraiment beaucoup ce sera vraiment
intéressant côté bancaires aux mains de
maximiser aussi justement des gars comme
woods des gars comme eric gordon ou à
table qui qui shoote dans cette équipe
lol attend un peu je excusé à
garrison mathieu garrison matthews josh
christopher qui était pas dégueulasse
non plus 30 % mais à trois points mais
c'était pas c'était s'était pas
complètement lettre je pense qui
justement il fait plein de petites
choses par lots qui vont pouvoir
qui vont pour maximiser les
l'efficacité offensive de houston qui va
pour apprendre les prises à deux aussi
par contre tu prends quand tu prends les
prises à deux tons à geelong green qui
est ouverte
qui viennent porter junior qui est
ouvert donc puis c'est vraiment un
joueur acquis une expertise là dedans
c'est à dire qui va reconnaître la prise
à dos qui va prendre la bonne décision
donc on a une espèce de mon alliance
lynch pin encre offensif qui
qui va faire en sorte que tout le monde
sur le terrain ont fait plus de sens
c'est pas un joueur qui avait tant le
ballon de sadio par rapport à d'autres à
d'autres prospère
dans d'autres dans d'autres contextes tu
penses que ça peut aussi être bien moi
j'ai une question très profonde sur le
banc quéro c est ce qui peut jouer plus
de 30 35 minutes dans un rythme effréné
comme celui de houston
avec son physique qu'est ce qu'il est je
pense qu'il va moi je pense qu'il va
ralentir le jeu du sein je pense qu'il
va ralentir et menacer le temps ne passe
pas que je pense pas qu on parle aussi
d'un gars qui comme un certain
leadership
donc moi je pense que ce soit y va
il faut pas jouer au rythme effréné non
plus je pense que c'est que je te dis
souvent
par l'eau baquero c1 c'est un
contrat qu'on signe avec son simple dans
mon coeur parle aux vainqueurs aux
injonctions le graff on joue comme lui
doit jouer lé bon jouer un jour on joue
un peu plus lentement mais ça s'est
passé parle de risque aigu
oui il mais parce que john green c'est
un joueur qui est efficace en transition
képi gc un jour qui passe sans
transition arthur c'est là où il y
donnent le meilleur d'eux mêmes ces
joueurs là
voilà c'est ça je l'assumerai moi en
tout cas vu comment ça grâce aux chères
pour l'instant les jeunes qui nous
rejoignent ce projet d'une construction
c'est que benjamin griveaux de la
première partie de saison et je veux
même pas 30 minutes par match quand je
regardais versus scotty barnes ou qe2 tu
en avais quasiment un différentiel de 6
minutes par match donc au final ouais ça
là ça a l'air d'être assez gestionnaire
avec les nouveaux talents limite s'il
veut pas trop les lancer dans le grand
bain d'entrée on peut cependant qu'il a
l'air d'avoir des soucis trans
conspiration je crois il perd 3,3 litres
d'eau par des pairs 3 kg par match comme
ça je sais plus mouais donc non je
compte je pense pas non je ne sais plus
le sucre ou je sais pas j'ai fait
mais si grand père un début de saison ne
sait pas pas un gros problème moi c'est
plus son moteur que ce concept qui
transpire
voisins et puis non je pense pas qu'on
va s'adapter vraiment pour moi sylvain
gayraud et sérieuse tonnes j'allais me
restera là
la pierre centrale de ceux de ce
dispositif et puis et puis en soit on a
du goût du cndd qui peuvent tourner à
trois banquiers ou à l'intérieur donc
je pense pas qu'on va s'adapter de
s'adapter et que banksy reviendra de
l'option des rouge et noir qu'on attaque
après
brillé non plus je crois que je crois
que jane green à long terme doit être un
jour dans lesquelles il vaut mieux
investir que ce soir que si on y va avec
le fit jabbari smith va être la guerre
qui va courir pendant
pendant 48 minutes avec tout le monde
mais ça est-ce que je ris mais doit être
sélectionné deux
c'est ce qu'on va voir le soir la rafle
c'est le meilleur fit un tabac oui oui
c'est clair mal mais
ça doit la plus soignée commande
d'envergure
je me suis réservé j'attendais
j'ai pas vu ton message souvent
je te je te mets sur la même question
que j'ai posée à benne au début mais qui
est un peu centrale est ce que dans
cette draft là il ya un joueur ou
plusieurs qui peuvent être des leaders
offensifs plus intéressant que jane grey
on peut être plus rapidement un jour
efficace jeu rapidement un joueur qui
score et ça peut être un très très bon
partenaire pick and roll avec les deux
gosses pas parce que tu coures tout le
temps que tu peux enfin le bunker
n'arrivera pas non plus à suivre le
rythme c'est pas on n'est pas chaud du
lucarne n'est pas sûr halpérin de
soutenir beaucoup il peut jouer de la
transition et après quand tu coures
derrière d'ulysse 32 le fait très bien
avec new york par exemple il peut jouer
la transition et puis qu'après tu peux
poser aujourd'hui terrain car à marier
les plaisirs il peut il peut y pose la
balle au sol il l'a remonte donc moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien les deux
mêmes victimes jabbari smith semble le
fit parfait selon 'aujourd'hui fit avec
les roquettes
arthur est ce que ta démission sur sur
les prospects dans le dans le chat aussi
merci pour tous vos comptes et reste que
vous avez des questions à bahia céline
qui nous demandent ça déjà
si d'être là céline est ce que houston
n'a pas intérêt d'aller chercher un pile
deux du coup pour s'assurer jabal
sait il aurait là il aurait le meilleur
partenaire avec un sens précis pour sam
presti vous trouverez une machination
pour le faire fonctionner cissé joie
qu'ils veulent
je crois que les
lions auront probablement un pic de
2 le big 17 ou un autre pk donnait pour
mai
je peux voir quelque chose fonctionner
avec cookie si facilement
arthur toi t'es content de nous piquer
en 3 ou est ce que tu dis
cette gêne pas de lâcher je sais pas
antique de 2024 pour aller pour monter
en deux
bonnes questions pour cent à partir de
2024 on aura pu nous nous piquent à nous
mais c'est vrai merci chris paul
et non soit le 3 cette année c'est un
peu la meilleure place contre guillemets
la moins pire on va dire parce qu'on
soit un taux de 3 qui est vraiment
dégagé on va dire avec 3 à 3 joueurs
donc en fait au final on va choisir le
meilleur joueur restant
finalement un peu la place des cases
dernière qui ne mettait un peu la
pression avec mobley donc non je n'ai
plutôt content
comment visiter sacha dans pokémon en
fait tard il ya plus bizarres qui a
rappelé à la même bande ouvrant pikachu
donc au final on est tellement abc on
est tellement à 10,6 sur le détroit les
prend en tête que final c'est un peu la
bonne place pour nous après c'est sûr
qu'il ya des joueurs qu'on préfère et et
je pense que ok si avec qui on trafique
beaucoup depuis des années
dernièrement c'était csn gogniat
l'encontre de first bien protégés donc
moi je pense que les numéros sont vient
d'enregistrer des deux côtés est un
moyen de monter un truc après je pense
que si il arrive un moment de leur
construction il faut vraiment prendre le
meilleur talent possible et passer un
gros cap donc je vois mal précis lâcher
tu sais pas si on arrache hangar où bat
plus en plus nos 3 et d'autres pics et
je vois pas aussi le côté stoned trop
lâché dans le sang sont en fait on a un
peu la bonne place comme je disais ou
quoi qu'il arrive on va sortir avec un
pantalon donc pas bon je ne vois pas
lâcher notre notre force 2023 et je
pense que c'est un trépied qui aura
jamais lieu après le pic 17 ans soit on
peut il va facilement bouger je pense
important par alex sauf si ça me presti
n'est pas d'accord avec raphaël stone
sur le potentiel de tel ou tel joueur
c'est à dire magie non j'ai pas le magic
a pris
jason
raphaël stone pense que jabari ce mythe
est meilleur sam presti pense que banque
héros et médias
c'est un appel festiludis gros moi je
vais absolument à paris
et voilà ça se fait quoi parce que
christie va récupérer le joueur qui
voulait plus quant à 7
7 6
quid des possibilités de trades ben
c'est en
c1 gmfl stone qui a été très actif
depuis qu'il est arrivé
il a créé des azalées stewarts point
robert covington ou qui avaient stewart
et c'est dès qu'il est arrivé des
simples la première draft ensuite donc
il pour ramener christian ude
ensuite année d'après arthur l'a rappelé
très pur interne shimbun il c'est
quelqu'un qui a pas peur est ce que tu
dois bouger est ce que tu vois obligé
avec une croix ou avec le 17 avec le 17
probablement moi je dis qu'il ya
peut-être sept chances sur dix qu'ils
c'est vraiment une évaluation de comme
ça mais
mais oui c'est un ascète qui est de la
valeur à ce rang lors de 12 de ses
épaules c'est pas à maximiser la valeur
de mon pays que c'est qui va prendre le
joueur qu'on aime avant nous essayer de
se placer
si on se rappelle l'année dernière
cuisse droite et est parti
elin x avait tué deux bacs de meuron du
numéro 19 parce que il n'avait aucun
aucun des joueurs qui voulaient donc se
sont rendus au numéro 25 donc c'est un
plus ce jeu là c'est soit que le beau
jeu aussi de se trouver joie de rotation
qui fonctionne à 17 il va en avoir
plusieurs des ailiers on n'a jamais
assez délié efficace et compétent et de
billets et athlétique il va y en avoir
une coupe dont le der woude simone de
mai mais oui c'est un tireur à 7
[Musique]
et
je crois qu'il va réussir à façonner le
moindrement joueurs de poker com
[Musique]
surtout que si je compte bien le en
juillet joe strip ce temps mais il reste
au moins une ou deux place dans le
roster avec tous les joueurs qui s'en
vont qui sont sans contrat etc oui oui
peut-être que tu peux aussi
avoir des vétérans que ce soit eux
qu'est ce que tu en penses
au niveau de la de l'acquisition de
valeur puisque c'est ça la draft
conquiert des joueurs qui ont de la
valeur en investissant dessus à moindre
coût est ce que ça vaut le coup de 13h
de traits d'un avec le 3d ready set et
après on ira
d'objets pas que ça forcément et parce
que c'est rare on se rappelle d'été
tournée de markale felt mais c'est un
cas assez exceptionnel j'ai l'impression
dans la nba c'est moderne d'un titre
ayant effectivement
travail donne cependant pas nous je
pense pas non plus parce que je ne veux
vraiment faire sa reconstruction là ils
vont c'est d'avoir le plus gros talent
de sauf si comme nous le disait juste
avant ils voient peut-être en ainsi
bronn un jab à will smith a mais comme
ça plus talentueux mais qui pourrait
avoir
ça va dépendre de l'appréciation qu'ils
sont des autres des autres jim et je
suis une équipe comme houston
effectivement j c'est d'abord le plus de
jeunes joueurs parce que les vétérans
que j'ai en ce moment sont pas des vrais
vétérans c'est pas des mecs qui vont se
stabiliser à investir cristiano ne va
pas à assainir un vestiaire donc je vais
essayer d'avoir des talents et je laissé
un arrière de trouver des vrais gars
pour pour poser tout ça un petit peu et
essayer de développer mes gars parce que
quand on aime beaucoup trop de jeunes on
peut voir que des fois c'est la
débandade sachant quand tu vois tu as
chaud que je regarde les jeunes justin
donc sans manquer de respect aux jeunes
de houston mais on n'est pas sur les
mecs les plus posées quoi on n'est pas
sur les galets plus en mon nom je me
disais
[Musique]
oui c'est ces jeunes it if i profite bon
ben voilà il faut des clips ils font du
doubs ipcc c'est cool mais on ramène moi
a ramené deux mois dé gains peu un peu
expérimenté derrière un très bon coup
des caouecs tempel des joueurs comme ça
très propre pour
développer développer en avec 2 mondial
de l'intelligence avec en fond sans mal
à mener une culture même si arthur il ya
ya ya lorsqu'ils sortent dans ce qui
sort à droite à gauche une vraie
croyance ont la culture du travail que
peut apporter au challenge c'est
quelqu'un de bien qui est chaud avec eux
mais qui base du temps dans le gymnase
c'est un gros bosseur c'est celle que ce
côté un peu de rythme un peu je m'expose
sur les réseaux avec avec des chiens et
des bijoux qui coûte le prix de mon
appart
donc oui c'est un gros bosseur et puis
moi j'aime bien cette mentalité un peu
de drogue ce que peuvent avoir du jeu ce
christopher du tate
mêmes même du 10 août qui est assez
vocal finalement aussi même s'il prouve
pas forcément tout ça sur le terrain
donc il est là on parlait de vétérans et
aussi eric gordon il faut pas négliger
et qui a l'air de l'être sur les papiers
pour la saison prochaine donc on soit je
trouve que l'équilibré est plutôt est
plutôt là il pas non plus maximale mais
fait pas non plus prendre cette équipe
de houston pour le club de vacances ça
aller sur le terrain et dans le
vestiaire ça là datera assez
à ces fins moins pire de ce que de ce
qu'on peut lire un peu dans certains
médias ou autre
après voilà c'est surtout avec le temps
se calme et ça va prendre en maturité
la direction semble assez assez sereine
aussi jeu de plan a l'air de suivre son
cours il ya longtemps que c'est assez
maîtrisée des résultats sont pas là et
c'est assumé donc donc donc voilà hâte
de voir ce qu'on se voie choisir la
draft sachant que ça a l'air d'être ait
des dégâts assez sérieux et et pas trop
non plus enfin ça quand même des grandes
gueules je pense à smith
sacrée gueule mais il à ceux sur
qui est le plus des trois nouveaux cas
lambic
mais c'est plus calme qu'à l'époque du
ardennes tucker chris paul qui s'était
un peu le concours de la plus grosse
donc c'est non en soit on se vendent
assez content de tout ça surtout le dos
christopher je pense qu'eux mêmes garuba
aussi qui s'inspire beaucoup de demandes
grint ya une sorte de vraiment une
mentalité de de défense avec moi
peut-être sonné mais on s'est vraiment
de passer par la défense pour ensuite
enchaîner sur l' attaque avec jaden et
qui habite chez qui nous régale d'ayoub
donc c'est ça on est pas la plante pour
l'instant ce cas ça reste jeune c'est ça
qu'il faut
mieux que gay men dans le dans le top 5
quels sont les joueurs qui
irait le mieux défensivement pourrait le
plus apporté défensivement et faire et
développer ou cacher les défauts c'est
selon des cinq goudé christiane route
des
bo gars en bas qui a pas eu beaucoup de
temps de jeu pour l'instant kenyon
martin junior qui qui qui couvre le
poste 4 ginals en sortie
pour moi on va revenir toujours alors tu
y est effectivement qui peut être un
prospect défensif exceptionnel mais
l'avantagé avec jeff barry smith comme
si tu essaies qu' il peut si moi je
crois pas dans le switch
m je ne crois pas dans le fait qu'ils
puissent y toujours des extérieurs il
peut jouer en complément d'un même ap
rangoon il peut exister à côté de lui en
facilement par l'ansa peut développer
ton jeune ça peut développer un carreau
bas parce qu'il peut jouer à côté et ça
peut aussi couvrir le haut niveau du
pick and roll comme il a des mains très
très agressif qu'il est très très fort
pour monter haut sur le porteur de balle
et venir casser les pions de là dessus
il peut faire le la trappe l'effort que
jane green ou kpodji ne feront pas sur
le jour le premier point aux attaques
donc voilà vraiment être disruptive et
est montée très très haut ça peut
vraiment intéressant ça peut donner un
petit lot défi très agressive à houston
et gêné de la transition même s'il ya
des fautes voilà lancé un une première
chose défensif pour cette équipe après
généralement ce pont ces schémas année
les cif ben il faut derrière puisque tu
vas aller c'est râpé ou edge et fort il
faut derrière les trois derrière des
joueurs trouvent protégées le cercle qui
sont mobiles ont même si ce sont des
ailiers ou des arrières donc est ce que
tu vois je stone le personnel déjà
d'efficacité ce qui est on sait qu'il
nous ment qui jappe mêlée cela hurle et
laisse la
droite avec les avions
passé dans le ciel mais
trois des jeunes certes j'ai toujours
plus ses mails la capacité d'un symbole
à protéger cercle que que que la plupart
des gens je crois qu'ils plus athlétique
que ce qui laisse mon texte qui ont mon
prix surtout cette année à houston parce
qu'ils avaient quand même un rôle assez
précis
jabberi se mettre un gars qui est
calibre avec projette comme quelqu'un
est incapable de protéger le cercle des
sauces et c'est intéressant aussi côté
défensif fait pas l'aubaine queiroz
je crois qu'il va est quelque chose que
je crois qu'il va développer comme un
défenseur en ait qui sera ce rapport des
trois des trois joueurs au top ça sera
pas le seul des trois qui vont pas
tarder françois plus plus selon moi dans
la nuit
avant de partir sur le pic 17 luc
imagine que houston visa d'or jaden
haïti qui est disponible en 3 qu'il ne
choisisse est-ce que comment ils
s'insèrent offensivement ce que faut
aussi parler de cette hypothèse qui
existent vu que nous avons c'est pas ce
qu'il va se passer
sa santé sur un truc de talent tu peux
très bien jouer plus petit la nba s'est
pas non plus à mener ou feinte du mode
vous tout le monde peut porter le ballon
donc tu peux très bien me chagrine sur
le post 3 tu peux c'est trouver des
solutions comme ça tu vas les faire
sortir du banc si tu penses que c'est
ton meilleur talent que kevin porter
d'une heure peu patraque l'honneur à
terme nba titulaire d'une équipe qui
reconstruit faut se poser la question il
ya eu beaucoup de pertes de balle un
député avait beaucoup de progrès tu
penses que tu donnes avis peut être ce
mec là et que tu as envie d'avoir deux
formes holender battu pas changé d'avis
sachant que des intérieurs tu pourras en
avant peut-être moins coup peut-être
qu'ils croient fort peut-être quand il
disait tu pourras voir des mecs comme
mark williams ou encore kessler qui ont
une cote actuellement donc si pour eux
c'est le meilleur joueur pour y aller
sachant que tu donnes a très bien joué
moi du ballon dieudonné vient montrer
qu'ils sont des écrans qui tire très
bien 3.4 chaîne chez sa plus grosse aux
spécialités qui peut il se remettre en
direction qui peut coûter par ses
qualités athlétiques un jour très
collectif donc pour moi ça arrive évier
ou même shedden sharp toujours plus
arrière y'a pas de soucis tu gagneras
pas beaucoup de matches mais il n'y a
pas de souci pour son développement
on le développement de l'e mailing ni
pour celui de la vie
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup l'idée d'aller
chercher
ça vient régler un problème
arthur
est ce qu'on va chercher avec nos pics
17 est ce que parce qu on est vraiment
au niveau de la draft non mes trois
petits à qui ça c'est sera le boulot de
lullier ben idir qui éventuellement mais
on est au niveau de la draft où il ya un
vrai choix à faire plus qu'avec le petit
croix c'est de se dire je prends un gros
risque avec un gars qui a un plancher
vraiment très bas mais qui peut être
fait pas un titulaire quoi ce qui
libérera en choisissait on devrait
titulaire n'diaye ou alors je prends un
gars qui est un rôle player et qui va
être tous aller mieux mon 5e 6e 7e 4
rotations mais qui va certainement faire
une carrière au moins de deux contrats
non cette année
avec les défaites se sont enchaînées ça
qu'on s'est renseigné très tôt sur les
joueurs dont j'ai bien quelques petits
dont six favoris on va dire mais c'est
sûr que là le pi 3 on va prendre
le meilleur le plus gros potentiel pour
devenir all star était un peu attractive
donc c'est sûr le pic de 17 mois c'est
que je suis de plus en plus convaincus
convaincre le trade peut-être associé
avec gordon ou aroud parce que c'est
vrai que la dernière on a quand même
quatre premiers quatre premiers 4ce
rooted du premier tour plus là on en a
encore deux à deir on en a 17 moins de
deux ans a fait 15 nous reste quinze pic
15 first quasiment dans le 15 km en 15
cliquer sur les six prochaines saisons
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de pick et
j'ai peur qu'on amasse tellement de
talent qu'au final on les gâches ça que
garou bas c'est un peu la peur que le
plu j'ai donc le pic de 17 3 mois j'ai
dû jovovich qui m'intéresserait dans
chat advisor extrapoler les soucis de la
rocqué nation seul ombre vient beaucoup
du queen's ignore aussi si ce n'est pas
d'arrêter avant mais moins de taito
washington qui est pas mal appréciée en
back up de dallas qui est un képi jay ça
peut être aussi aux cycliques ans donc
il n'y a qu'à noter que non mais je
pense que ouais ça va rester dur le
payeur en sortie de banc et qui reste
intéressant à développer ou alors si oui
si on clique on est plutôt sur durolle
payeurs que de tenter un une folie une
potiche skis pour pour dire
c'est sa limite on peut plus drafté au
feat j'ai l'impression que qu'au talent
limite un poste 3 avec le post croit
houston depuis je suis fan c'est
compliqué depuis 2000 tous et met en
cause tel profil un stoppeur ou plus un
shooter
évidemment on espère qu'ils peuvent
faire
freddy si si possible après le texte
c'est vrai qu'on a moi je crois encore
que keep équipe en devenir a appris à
trois points ça reste un peu compliqué
c'est un peu ça sa seule faiblesse mais
oui un fruit bien peu on peut un peu
sexy et qui soit beau ça ça bosse leur
tour dans cette mentalité dogues ce
qu'on essaie de développer et qui peut
courir aussi
fait beaucoup de beaucoup de choses à
demander combien ça se trouve on bondit
le chat propose un bon cd j'étais déjà
venu un peu plus tôt alors je viens
d'être un pont
il sera pas là
depuis longtemps
hôpitaux psychiatriques mais partie
toujours le sien tous les clubs tous les
clubs sont en amour avec le potentiel
de tara wilson c'est une question temps
avec quelqu'un
c'est sur la gâchette dans le top 10 et
comme le remarque paul on en a déjà
parlé avec hugues dans la vidéo
d'épaisseur et on trouve
enfin il est plus probable qu'il faudra
fêter au pays soeur nancy ce que rocket
moi je reste en big bang un navet je
sais mais j'étais cité va pas regarder
la vidéo metz-tessy
[Musique]
souvient de dix en 17 jours
idéalement il john williams c'est parce
qu'il a la cote de ouf et que moi je
l'avais vers la médiane à 2001 puis ça
passe plus j'ai l'impression qu'il va
partir aux knicks en 11 mois mais tient
à 1000m c'est le profil du soutien dit
parfait qui a
faim cas c'est assez peu mise en lumière
à santa clara
vraiment c'est pour moi le meilleur
défenseur sur les ailes de la cuvée l'
hyper intelligent vraiment toujours bien
placé athlètes avec une très très très
belle envergure à quelle transition il
est trop fort tir à trois points on a
encore quelques infos comme quoi ils
tiraient avec des plus gros volumes tout
ce qu'il a pu montrer à santa clara et
qui est les termes d'efficacité il a
tout tenté au combat et donc la cote
elle est vraiment en train de monter et
en plus de ça sur des renversements
c'est un très bon passeur tout que je
crois pas particulièrement dans la
création balle en main parce que les
dribbles passes et d'imiter le poulpe
trois points pas forcément là mais c'est
un traitement passant de cap le
fluidifier une attaque ça peut vraiment
être un un parfait complément de des
joueurs de delio
avec trois ans de maturité dans le jeu
physique
alors attention j'ai vu j'ai bougé vu ça
mais un joueur ultra productif
peut-être que les équipes vu les
l'historique récent des joueurs de nick
mais d'ordre a fait assez haut des
pannes des superstars qui n'était pas
déjà mort en tout cas un jeune colon
peut-être que les knicks par exemple
dans 11
c'est quelle équipe avant va se
refroidir aussi et qui pourrait être là
en dix-sept ont cassé une hypothèse qui
n'est pas parce le dialogue il aime ce
qui est pour toi un des meilleurs
défenseurs de la cuvée sur les airs et
aristote immédiat
en termes de maturité ya un monde
d'écart le potentiel physique de kahone
est incroyable médias l'année williams
eu ce qui fait c'est pour moi c'est une
niveau de ce que mathis title pouvait
faire pas vraiment c'est impressionnant
wilson il fait 6 fautes en 20 minutes
donc je les aime beaucoup mais laisse un
chien quoi il se jette sur tout le monde
john williams un stoppeur il arrive de
man nba tu y mets le en mission sur le
meilleur volant de leurs ailiers
adverses il peut faire vraiment un vrai
travail comme taiwo l'a fait comme qui
avait donné aux objets plus et des
groupes stoppeur défensif peut le faire
michael bendis comme le mac à oasis du
désert
on dit au china jc glisse un peu
loppsi le chat ne serait ce
qu'un bon
le but tomas s'est passé un peu cette
cohérence là de donner des options à
geelong ring et un
autre nom pour vous les gars
l'indicé je pense que
si ça glisse
daniel celle-ci par top 10
vu tout ce qui sort
c'est pas que du bruit des journalistes
basket tu vois c'est doux et les agences
et du corps idée exacte du billet
mungo jerry sochan aussi qui est annoncé
le plus loin que j'ai vu 18
mois le meilleur de france à la draft
crois que c'est lui
et puis c'est un des joueurs très
intéressant justement à glisser dans un
effectif qui va est efficace à peu près
tout dit très jeune vient tout juste
d'avoir 19 ans donc c'est non c'est non
intéressant et sakho et jérémy tellement
tellement taulard c'est moi
oui bah oui alors ils ont dit qu'il y en
a tellement mais moi je suis pas en
cette cheveux tout à fait d'accord avec
vous parce que
on a l'impression qu'il y en a beaucoup
parce qu'on s'imagine des choses on se
dit lui va shooter lui va défendre une
telle et telle aujourd'hui il a enfin ce
qui fonctionne en nba il son élite en
défense ou au tir et ils savent faire
l'autre chose mais ils sont élite dans
un dé de quoi c'est pas juste savoir
faire les deux c'est être hérite dans
l'un des deux et savoir-faire l'autre
sochan pour moi il y est déjà et l'état
défend je le mets dans mes matins sur
n'importe qui en nba faisait pas par un
missile tiré
ça c'est oui mais c'est que j'en parlais
aux gens parlaient ou sur le podcast
espère jeudi dernier qui est sorti sur
les réseaux aujourd'hui à des voix c'est
des problèmes qui sont réglables chez la
chatte un culte au dessus de la tête
comme calais faisait au collège je suis
pas qu'il va devenir kawhi leonard mais
je vous ai des problèmes qui sont
réglables avec la répétition puis un
oeil c'est pas son tir est passé
ont effectivement donc jérémy serein
t'avais dit dizaine daniels qui on a
d'autres dans notre bord de danse et oh
là là qui gêne leur n appartient qu anne
marie prêtera serment je crois mais ça
soit 1,17 pour moi ça serait ce serait
juste pour qu'ils méritent a dit qu'il
pourrait rejoindre un collectif os qui
pourrait apporter de la valeur qui est
proportionnelle à son rang de draft
parce que là les gens s'énervent avec
lui puis quoi il voit juste ce n'est pas
le tout
est ce que est ce que vous arthur a cité
très justement geovic tout à l'heure qui
devrait dans les autres dans ces eaux-là
hughes est ce que tu peux parler de
nicolas jovic way nicolas dovic c'est un
joueur qui joue alors tu m'as dit vire
le nouveau nom c'est kakamega mozart
maintenant basket san aux armements et
moins jeunes donc c'est un pas il faut
avoir de très grande taille qui à terme
mesurer la cispi ronge
je crois donc c'est de mettre 10 dans
notre système à nous qui est capable de
dribbler passer chute est
vraiment un joueur très créatif
parlement que j'aime beaucoup
défensivement c'est un peu plus
compliqué il ya un très très gros
caractères il y avait des questions sera
scouting rep avoir lâché la main gauche
en point faible voilà j'ai regardé les
derniers masques qui tombent et je
savais que c'était quand même vachement
mieux
ma question va avec ce joueur c'est est
ce qu'il va pouvoir exister loin du
ballon en nba est-ce qu'il va l'accepter
et qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir proposer un
genre de situation là mais sur le profil
de joueur c'est du kif absolue avec de
11,1 de 2 d'ici peu au tableau de chasse
de troll
après il ya le voilà la switch habilité
est-ce que ça switch beaucoup en défense
arthur ou est-ce qu'on est plus dans ce
schéma conservateur
on a beaucoup de succès sur la première
saison de star hélas
comme vous l'avez vous avez pu le voir
ça a très bien marché donc on a vite
laissé tomber tout ça et non non on est
vraiment sur un système classique on
essaie vraiment de donner le moins
possible de deux ballons oppose
notamment surtout quand on en défenseur
du type woods en 5 donc non par contre
il ya un truc assez intéressant c'est
l'alignement de 3 2 points 3 point guard
shooting voir donc avec christopher g
cup et capi jay est souvent quand on
aligne ce ces trois là on voit que les
dauphins de c'est défensive le racing
soit assez bon et on passe sur une
défense en zone
avec notamment garuba qui a fait de
belles séquences en tout cas moi j'ai
bien kiffé et fans et aux pièces on le
sait c'est compliqué le qui fait
défensivement depuis quelques années
mais mais ouais donc on peut faire des
zones avec un beau gars au ballet trois
points gordes entre guillemets sont les
postes en 2 3 et du cndp qui viennent en
4/5 donc donc donc pas trop de switch
pas pour l'instant
ça tombe bien pour tours jovovich et
peut-être pour patrick baldwin aussi qui
a été proposé par ko mac
le chat qui était en quasi top 10 mais
le top 10 je crois au début de l'année
sur espn j'ai pas la faute au monde
c'est un peu le même profil que lio vite
ch ben embrach grands grands bras
je vais vite et quoi je vais c'était osé
maureen josé mourinho va bien je devrais
pas parler je devrais pas parler
parce que je vais être que je vois des
gros gros problème si je parle
moi j'y crois pas c'est un joueur qui je
crois vraiment beaucoup le premier
mesurer ou qu'en pense que j'étais
vraiment agréablement surpris mais je
crois qu'il a fait le moins euros le
vertical le - oddo
cie qui quand même pas très
physiquement qui est quand même pas très
sains c'est un profil créé stationnaire
c'est à dire que ça avait un shooter
qu'on va mettre dans un coin
ces points golgoht le plus dur non plus
donc goyer moi je suis pas je suis pas
fan du tout de baldwin j'ai pas vu
beaucoup nicolas you vite donc je me
proposerait poste mais
moi moi je dirais non direction surtout
avec les deux deux chiens enragés à la
manne qui vont qui vont le terroriser
s'il fait des conneries
je lui seul un profil typique de joie
que je reviendrai à la fac si j'étais
lui
je crois que c'est vraiment bien mais je
transpirais je la cherchais je vais
chercher un autre profil quelqu'un qui a
une vraie vision de qui je pourrais
devenir mais non je pense pas qu'il va
revenir mais ça va être une erreur
bon
évidemment il ya toujours plein de noms
mais mais effectivement là on a cité au
moins ce qui était spécialiste dans un
domaine donc c'est à dire soit le shoot
soit la naissance
suite ensuite il faut progresser dans
l'autre au moins être au niveau il y
avait autre shayk jimmy si vous pouvez
aller voir façon on a soit un podcast a
minima poutine report pour tous les
joueurs donc si vous notez les monts
ce sera assez facile à retrouver
arthur pour revenir optique 3 et pour
commencer à conclure
il faut faire un board il faut qu'on
établisse un big bang requête avec un
numéro un du mois parce que même si je
sais pas il se passe un truc tu as les
piquants numéro un
peu probable mais c'est possible il faut
faire un board 1 2 3 4 5 allez on va
aller jusqu'à cinq
fois le joueur que tu préfères dans ce
conte a décrit à houston
le meilleur fitou le couture
le
nom celui que lui tu pense qu'il va le
mieux fonctionné quoi
ben là c'est pour moi c'est très clair
pour moi c'est déjà barry smith de pas
de loin mais c'est ce cas c'est un peu
la leur suggère jabari smith le fils
parfait
en cage a parlé aussi
si tu as le 1 2 27
compliqué
je t'avoue que j'abats grid est vraiment
hyper intrigant et puis ça son shoot qui
y perd mature j'ai l'impression pour
pour son âge ça peut vite devenir un
monstre
un monstre dans la ligue donc je t'avoue
chet en fait pour moi c'est le pic un
saint est le 1 mais il ya quand même
beaucoup de risques que j'ai
l'impression de pas de partir soit en
baisse mais sans tout casser pour moi
c'est le top 3 c'est celui qui est le
plus risqué après c'est sûr que ça va
cliquer et que ça va me sortir la vidéo
dans un an ou deux mais mais
franchement je serais un [ __ ] je serai
pas non plus certain de prendre chet
alors de jour de l'an
ben c'est guitton joueurs préférés toit
pour les raquettes le côté fit côté fait
ce soit aussi jabbari ce mythe mais le
droit des trois sites schengen c'est le
joueur qui change le plus la donne
l'année prochaine avec ça avec sa
protection du cercle les autres équipes
vont être vraiment terrifié par ça va
vraiment changer la donne
moi c'est vraiment de loin mon préfet
dans tout ça très flou c'est mon préféré
je crois que les trois équipes au top
d'oeuvre est étroit gm devrait se battre
à l'intérieur d'un cercle pour savoir
qui a droit
chaque congrès
lui étaient d'accord sur le nom de la
banque
ouais mais pas juste
pour le coup pas houston parce que la
trop des diodes de solutions offensives
et je parie arrive pas à me projeter
bonne clearwire ce monsieur j'arrive pas
je mettrais jet jump smith et je pense
qu'ils vont prendre chez dunlop
c'est ma grosse cage ouais je pense que
justin doit prendre sa nature c'est mal
c'est la grosse cote que j'agisse
feeling peut-être que j'ai aussi envie
que sacramento est capable smith mais je
pense que voilà pour moi ci doit tomber
en droit dans le top 5 c'est la borde
et bah alors à temps
et dans l'idée chez d'un uncharted mais
très haut sur ton bord de roquettes si
toi tu étais gm des rockets
c'est moi j'étais deuxième des rockets
103 devant paul pour les roquettes parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'ils aiment
beaucoup les athlètes j'ai l'impression
qu'ils veulent vraiment créer du
spécisme maximum avec beaucoup de tirs
ciel défensif peut être hyper excitant
que je suis pas sûr que kpodji ce soit
leur meneur à terme et que lé peuvent
avoir un amant un truc athlétique énorme
et
vienne l'équipe que je vois bien les
joueurs de l'intrigué et qui a peut-être
moins l'impression que ok si qui doit
prouver des choses que au nouveau qui
qui a qui a pas souvent l'occasion de
briller je pense que c'est eux qui peut
pas les chercheurs très vite
il ya des bons
mais les kings
à paris
ben hilli ucia si tu tiens un board
roquettes à jets ont ensuite c'est quoi
g
et quand la la la vision de dieu qui est
vraiment très séduisante j'ai presque
envie de le mettre entre deux
je ne sais pas l'idée
absolument inestimable
je vais
je mets donc jal et veut mettre un cap
may mais j'avoue qu'ils des jeux parce
que on oublie souvent on pense que que
celle en charpie d'un meneur mais c'est
un gars qui fait si c'est si ce qui est
encore extrêmement développé qui vont
pouvoir jouer au poste 3 facilement une
bille et donc ça
[Musique]
il à l'ossature aussi la carrure pour
ajouter du muscle pour l'instant il est
un peu léger il est à
96,17 de 11 un mur ils m'ont dit
estimant ces immenses brad à wii pc on
veut frapper si on veut aussi on veut
prendre
une bonne claque la ccc lui convient si
on vise pour le sial en visite chez des
peuples
oui et c'est ce qui est et ce qu'arthur
disait et c'est ce que rémy disait aussi
en début de live
ci lui disait l'ami les mots qu'elle se
doit aller chercher le dalang si
tu te dis que le plus talentueux qui
reste en 3 sécher
bencharef la théorie du soutien de sa
très peur assure chez pelchat
non non c'est un jeu hyper excitant moi
c'est un peu mon pic tu vois un peu le
plus intrigant en fait j'ai vraiment
envie de voir ce que ça peut donner
mais tu vois si on va sur le pick 3 et
qu'on veut vraiment prendre le meilleur
talent possible si je la prendrai une
autre est une autre totalement ça va
être vraiment que moi je pense que là
est vite montée en 3 je vois ça va
dépendre aussi des interviews et les
dirigeants mais pour moi s'il ya
surprise et qu'on chope à un banquet
roja baril si ce qui sont encore là
pour moi on va plutôt aller chercher à
éviter voici il rafle est un autre gm
voit une future star en devenir et qu'il
est vraiment séduit par ce mental
d'acier mais charge dans ça reste un
joueur hyper hyper intrigant hyper
excitant c'est qu'ils l'avaient été
après il ya un peu cette interrogation
ce qui n'a pas joué cette année si j'ai
pas de bêtises donc donc voilà je mange
on y perd séduit mais après pour moi
quand tu es en trois et que qu'il ya
déjà un trio qui est qui qui détermine
est assez distincts tu peux pas prendre
le risque à ce moment là de la
reconstruction
très bien donc pour les fans priorité
jabbari ensuite par l'eau est peut-être
déjà de nay guichard chet selon
ceux-ci les deux autres sont partis j'ai
bien résumé ou pas
ouais
gemba sera sa seconde fois qu'il est
passé
non mais
monde apprend qu'aucun ne s'est pas un
risque sharp ou un même murray mais
c'est juste que voilà tu as déjà un trio
qui déterminer pourquoi les tenté de
prendre un joueur qui pourra peut-être
est un meilleur fit mais après on va se
faire taper dessus et qu'on est de
devenir les nouveaux kings hadraf quoi
alors là c'était plutôt l'inversé tu es
plutôt tenté de le penser en dehors de
la boîte des trois qui sont en haut et
se dire ben justement je m'en fous du
fiqh je m'en fous du fait que que ce
gars là il est un peu besoin du ballon
pour briller et je veux aller a ajouté
du talent après ce que disait ben en des
bus étaient été aussi
exactement le contre-argument de ça
c'est de se dire
c'est pas l'entêtement pour le genre de
joueur qui est chez venture c'est ce que
tu disais en début de live band
il ya beaucoup d'environnement il
pourrait bien se développer et les
roquettes sont peut-être malheureusement
pas partie belge passe je pensais les
assauts de chet n'ont donc dix sept
chinois
wei magescas ccc
ça c'est un
défaut
il faut
s'attendre à ce que jouera soit laissé à
lui même jusqu'à un certain point parce
que je commence un peu
le chaos là bas je pense qu'il ya un
système énorme de développement
tout du moins pas pour l'instant mais ce
mois ci je suis rafer alston je veux une
certaine garantie que j'améliore
l'équipe
je pense justement j'ai peut-être pas
besoin de vendre du spectacle je paye
pas besoin d'asseoir des gens dans les
sièges au juste améliorer l'équipe pour
l'instant donc j'irai pas taillé de plus
avec un jeu là mais je les laisse un cap
je laisse je répète peu savaient quelque
chose qui qui va être un bloc
qui est qui dans la cave à une vertèbre
dans la colonne vertébrale de l'équipe
d'atlantis ya une véritable équipe quand
même jeu très
confortable l'idée de laisser les clés
de toute façon c'est arthur vous avez
votre 2023
ça commence à être compliquée
commença à couiner en 2024
scouts henderson même si vous avez pas
victoire coûte 1 de chance ça va être
tout un joueur
aux harton seuls
[Musique]
savent pas c'est qui osa comme ça allez
voir sur le
stand qui avait personne le dunk qui
s'est transformée allez hop
c'était c'était de la haute-folie
oui c'est l'action la plus folle que
j'ai vu cette année or victor wanyama
c'est vrai le gold cobra sont hélas pas
pour donkey échanges d'idées en plein
milieu ils essaient de faire un lay up
une allemagne trop haut pour le lay up
fait qu'il finira donc c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable j'ai dû la regarde
les u moteur sonne l'année prochaine
tout ça pour dire nommé pour dire on
peut être mauvais l'année prochaine il
ya pas de problème c'est un salon je
pense que ça m'a mis enviable de trop
mais l'année prochaine deux bonnes
années pour elle c'est ça tu en vois
tout le monde et tu vois que tu peux
garder pendant cette auberge espagnole
de jeunes et ensuite c'est de garder
d'autres idées de développer un petit
stage est un bon petit battue peut aussi
d'avoir victor stable un très beau grand
tu peux écouter que c'était il ya plein
d'options donc allez-y be wild
absolument arthur tonton ton meilleur
scénario pour la draft night on pourra
là dessus le 3 le 17 qui se compteraient
toi tu le disais le 3 jabbari et le 17
qu'une trêve c'est ça ton scénario idéal
ouais c'est que la benne le disais tout
à l'heure c'est marrant ce que j'avais
je ne peux pas des petits articles pour
pouvoir un peu les différents scénarios
et sa figure est pas mis à part me
rendais papier ce serait du coup de
trade up avec les hornets ça mais il
perd du père louis n'en fait ce genre de
situation en fait tu alors envoyé aroud
et tu récupères implique s'approche du
top 10
voilà donc c'est un talent qui est vers
le levage 12 12 15 tu peux aller
chercher un bond de 6 jeunes pour moi le
3 tu le gardes je suis même pas je veux
même pas très 2 tout autre parce que en
termes d' asset comme on l'a dit de mes
23 c'est un peu le last
dernier moment où tu peux améliorer ton
équipe avant de plus rapide et commencé
quand même passer des caps avec tes
jeunes donc non tu restes avec 1,3 et tu
es tu prêt de faire un top 12 autres est
même allé chercher les knicks et bon ok
charlotte attrait et 15 effectivement 11
c'est nice 12 clippers
a dû comme indépendant dessus
david braben sénat c'est les clés passé
aucun incident ou c'est là le trait à la
mairie
scénario idéal aller je veux dire 3 john
barry smith et 17
17 on a parlé de well et moi je te
rassure john williams pour pour la
maturité jabber speech alan williams
sachant que je passais ben là dit mais
nous diabolise mais on y croit à terme
comme un pivot
on l'a on le fait jouer à côté de la
reine jeanne good mais à terme on y
croit comme un pivot donc ça nous laisse
du temps de déploiement alors ces jeux
je vais reprendre les mots de gregg
popovich
si tu peux jouer avec deux intérieurs si
les deux intérieurs savent faire des
passes c'est ça
oui c'est bien ça joue
oui
scénario idéal scénario idéal
numéro 3 que j'avais à 8 mètres c'est
sûr et set j'ai vu j'ai vu quelque chose
pas assez cjm sylvestre qui avait dit ça
dans les commentaires charles gil
malakal brême en 17 j'aime bien profil
bons changements de tempo aussi quand tu
enlèves
quand tu enlèves un gars comme gill en
green sur le sur le terrain c'est un
gars qui est beaucoup plus ordonnée qui
joue avec elle la houle qui est vraiment
qui est vraiment une bonne
qui écriront un profil physique
intéressant aussi donc source moi je
devrais être dans cette direction le
genre d'aller chercher un gars qui une
espèce de meneur cela chewing qui peut
jouer avec le ballon qui peut jouer le
même sens bâle peut défendre sans ballon
un truc comme ça un joueur ou
bien voilà on a les trois scénarios
idéaux pour houston avec une dent jantes
une colonne vertébrale jabbari smith il
est parti avant il est parti à nancy
candidats et c'est qu'on va retenir de
ce live puisque de toute façon annoncé
des hypothèses on ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer et je réponds juste à aller au
delà qui nous demandent s'ils manquaient
des faiblesses au show de char tu peux
aller écoutez notre podcast sur lui mais
sharks est quasiment 40% à 3 points sur
quatre 75% de tir créé pour lui même
donc disons qu'à trois points ya pas
trop de soucis mais peut-être en catch
and shoot comme un qu il y analyse en
avait pas
puisque
les moines le qui met en avant la
faiblesse des pourcentage aux lancers
francs ce qui
répète souvent dans le podcast mais peut
être lié à des préférences motrices
c'est à dire des problèmes à gauche
pour entrer leur show donc donc
peut-être que chez des sharks ce sera
moins efficace qu en catch and shoot en
poule sommes un des rares joueurs
mais c'est difficile à projeter mais
c'est par mois ajouté
pour répondre à la question arthur merci
beaucoup de ta présence avec nous merci
à vous merci ce qui s'écoule à eux
qu'est ce qui se passe sur rockets de
ses chaînes france 1
prochainement
des écoutes on a nos émissions qui
s'appelle alors houston qui est scindée
en deux parties donc on fait des espèces
sur twitter et aurions fait du coup
aussi du tweet ch ou en fait on commente
en direct là on a commenté en direct la
loterie avec l'équipe de livingston que
j'embrasse
et voilà on voit aussi commenté la draft
en direct donc pour la loterie on
n'était pas loin des des 180 70 donc
c'est plutôt cool de ça avec la commune
des articles vont sortir sur des
prospects et puis et puis voilà qu on
était des roquettes grad des photos de
jacques bino tour de la piscine
ou alors on attend sagement la draft
a bien merci encore c'était super cool
de d'être là avec tous les devoirs
ramener aussi pas mal de fans des
roquettes dans le le chat et c'est
vachement vachement dynamique ce soir
c'était cool à tous évidemment je peux
pas prendre toutes les questions mais
mais sachez qu'on voit vos commentaires
et on les lit aussi ça nous donne de la
matière pour pour réfléchir belle
on est ensemble on sort
le procès prochain pré-draft hall dans
deux jours on va parler des détroits
ce sera avec antoine blanchard elle de
l'équipe avec l'équipe du compte
comment s'appelle des motards qui traite
l'actualité des sports de détroit et
avec l immense alain guillou qui sera là
avec eux ils se sont fait bien baisés à
la loterie
expo que tu commences à te laver avec
sept sites sur ça je vais monter la
vidéo
[Musique]
avoir été là et fort sa force à la
roquette mais chez nous mais évidemment
pour la draft ou souhaite le meilleur et
développé bien aux petits et donner du
temps de jeu à xiii link wings ils le
méritent pas ce qu'on aime beaucoup